look we were honoring beyonce for
podcast i think we all were at one
moment right
okay look
congratulations outstanding drama series
power's one of the most beloved shows on
television one thing we are sad is that
this may be the final season correct
courtney i'm not allowed to say you're
not allowed to say literally not allowed
to say no
yeah i can't can't answer that at all
okay well let's stick to the award
tonight omari omari you obviously won
two awards tonight how special is that
to receive an image award from uh
tonight it's particularly special
because uh
you know what my my daughter is has got
an ailing eye back home my son kind of
did some you know he's being a kid and
and uh it was right it was kind of
special because i was speaking directly
to these people that are up here with me
i was texting courtney i was texting
mark i was texting natori
um and so it shows you just how close we
are yeah and now where i was texting
them about nova and then you come up
here and then i'm like honey i'm a
little out of it she's like
i'll figure out who can accept your
award and i said no no i'm on the way
okay
and so
so
so forth to be the 50th anniversary in
renzo and i was just talking in that
interview about
75 years on earth and in life that being
diana ross and for her to be 25 years
older than this award and just for the
naacp and what it's meant 50 years we
kind of like a guy named 50. right it's
kind it all it's so it's a special night
my younger brother whispered to me he
said it's a good night for you to be
here so
that means a lot absolutely you know i
can't have you here not talk power sorry
guys uh seriously uh the cliffhanger the
cliffhanger of ghost angela tommy i mean
that whole thing with the shooting where
are we going to pick up next season how
are the emotions feeling on set when
you're shooting well okay so whatever
yeah we do we need to try and actually
that's true in the writers room too we
like to laugh the whole time because
it's such dark material but what i will
say about where we pick up is if you are
a power fan you can probably figure that
out okay if you've gotten used to
watching the show and you understand the
language of the show and the things that
we do to try to you know keep the show
exciting you probably can guess where
you're we're going to come back in yeah
i get a sense so angela's not dead well
tasha wishes she shot her herself
but you know
i didn't get the chance
i didn't get a chance
but uh but we'll see if angela is alive
or not it's interesting
i do have to talk to you guys a big
night president's award was uh given to
jay-z a lot of us are kind of fangirling
right now how are you feeling and does
he deserve that award well i just we
just fan-girled i mean i had a whole
baby moment with beyonce because her
twins and my baby are literally one
month apart
so that was a moment but i'm so proud of
jay-z you know i met her many times but
jay-z winning the president award he
deserves it and i think he's been an
artist who set the culture and also
changed the game of you know hip-hop and
i think he he killed it absolutely
anybody have any favorite jay-z songs
they want to rap for me real quick
oh you're laughing so you want to wrap
one
what came to mind when i said that what
came to mind
you gave me a little i know you had time
to think natori right on the carpet i
just took no i gave you a little and i
told you yes have somebody else do omari
do you want to give it a run
made whole say okay so make another
whole
ain't gonna didn't finish the day bro
this is pg this is fiji
so we parted ways like ben and j-lo
should have been did it but i've been in
the days though hey kill it just your
height man that's nice
jay is a jay is a special gifted cat and
uh
we all grew up
on his music um we've all been
influenced by these become a big brother
to me a lot like another hip-hop power
horse and uh and not being 50. so it's
kind of interesting to have them in my
life growing up in in hip-hop as much as
i did but very
big dudes who came up in a very small
environment where most people thought to
be small they became really big so shout
outs to sean corey carter absolutely
he's so influential last question you
guys we are right now it feels like
we're a little bit divided with the
jessie smullet uh case and
some people are feeling different yeah
we are divided but how are you guys
feeling with the uh what how everything
has turned out do you want to weigh in
on that
i think um
from the wisdom of experience we should
allow life to take a just
course
and not
i think assumptions
are a bad place to go in general and i'm
one who likes to actually see
what we all root for for our family and
our children which is justice
served the right way we're not there yet
okay well you sum that up you sum that
up for everybody well look
congratulations i hope you have some
dope places to put your trophies tonight
you all are getting one so congrats on
the win
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]